All right, so we're going to start our second recording
on book one of The Gay Science.
I'm Nathaniel, here as ever with John Muckelbauer and Nate DeProspo.
We're trying something new that came up in our last recording,
and rather than move on from book two to book one,
we are going to sit with this for a little bit.
We're going to follow Nietzsche's advice and ruminate,
digest book one a little bit more.
And so, Nate, John, where did the rumination leave you?
How was this experiment for you?
I mean, I'm not really concerned with repeating ourselves necessarily.
I just don't want to focus on the exact spots
that we were doing in that first episode.
So I ended up kind of moving towards the latter end of book one.
I did the same kind of thing because every time,
for obvious reasons, every time that you do this,
you start at the beginning of book one and you read through to the end of book one.
So I consciously started in the middle of book one
and read to the end and then went back to the beginning.
So just to kind of be fresh on the middle or later stuff.
I also, just as a side note to start,
I find myself kind of trying to,
resisting my kind of Hegelianism as I'm reading this
because I finished the dis, obviously,
and we don't have to talk about any of that.
But I find when I read Nietzsche,
my inclination is to be like,
oh, that's where it's Hegelian.
You know, which is not really,
that shouldn't be the point of just like,
oh, look, he's making a Hegelian point.
Because obviously,
all of philosophy is in some way indebted,
at least tangentially,
to the kind of Hegelian line.
So I've been straining to find a different interpretive lens
when I look at Nietzsche's writing.
But it's hard for me
because all the parts that attract me to Nietzsche
are also kind of what attract me to Hegel.
So it's hard for me to differentiate the dispositions at this point.
Like, for example,
what do you call these?
Like stanzas?
Aphorisms.
Aphorisms, right.
So number 26, for example,
is a really short one on page 100 for me.
Yeah.
Where he's talking about, you know,
What is life?
Life, that is.
Continually shedding something that wants to die.
Being cruel and inexorable
against everything about us
that is growing old and weak.
And then later,
he's like constantly being a murderer.
Is that what life is?
And to me, this is like,
that's obviously these aphorisms
are kind of impressionistic
and they're not declarations on Nietzsche's part.
But a lot of the kind of tone and direction of these
reminds me of some of those Hegelian lines
that I'm taking up.
And I wonder if you could,
I wonder if you guys could kind of differentiate
the dispositions in a helpful way here.
Because this one's like,
to me, it's like,
there's Hegel right there.
You know?
Well, yeah, I mean,
I see what you're saying,
especially in terms of sort of like
the focus on a kind of violence
or dying.
But, you know,
so yeah, 26 stood out to me.
And then also 24,
which is different forms of dissatisfaction.
And then also the signs of corruption,
which is the one immediately before that, 23.
And then, yeah,
I mean, so this is definitely,
you know,
we've talked about this a lot.
Nietzsche and Hegel,
both thinkers of becoming,
both thinkers of sort of like a,
like of an upheaval.
And yeah,
and, you know,
we'd have to like,
we'd have to maybe sit with
and think a little bit more
about the technical aspects
of the Elf Hebeln.
Right.
And if, you know,
reflecting back on that,
you know,
the,
that's,
there's always a constituent of failure
or a lack,
a sort of incapacity
to reach
or to dominate
or to totalize
something that then
perpetuates
the,
the negation,
right?
Or the,
that perpetuates
the Elf Hebeln.
And with all,
all of the ones,
there's a positivity
to all of,
um,
Nietzsche's writing on,
on becoming,
on,
on transformation,
uh,
as in like,
like the activity
of a murdering,
the activity
of the violence,
the sort of,
the taking out
of an aggression
upon.
Um,
yeah.
And that,
you know,
and,
and like in the,
so the juxtaposition
between 23 and 24
is really interesting
to me
because in,
in 24,
the different forms
of dissatisfaction,
I'm going to talk about
them backwards,
actually.
He's talking about
the weak.
what in the Genealogy
of Morality,
he describes
as slave morality
and,
you know,
um,
uh,
and,
in several important
places in the Genealogy
talks about how
slave morality,
it's introspective,
it feels,
it takes in,
and it makes life
interesting.
It,
it,
it makes human life
in many ways
worth living.
It makes it
distinctly human
and something similar
is happening
in 24 here.
These sort of like
these lines of
dissatisfaction,
inability to exert
one's strength
and he sort of
genders it
along feminine
and masculine
lines.
And,
And it's the
feminine line
that's far more
interesting for him
in that it's an
innovation that makes
life more beautiful
and profound,
a strong discontent,
this capacity of
being affected,
gladly letting
themselves be
deceived from
time to time
and occasionally
resting content
with a bit of
intoxication
and gushing
enthusiasm.
And so here is
this sort of like
response to
strength,
aggression that
is inward
focusing,
but then also
like innovative
in its power
to be subjugated,
to be affected,
much like what
we were talking
about in our
last recording
about this,
this kind of
nobility,
the noble and
the common
in aphorism
three,
where this,
the nobility
of being,
where reason
pauses and
the noble is
capable of
being taken
up,
subjected
by passion.
Right.
And so
there's that
side of
what's going
on,
that side
of this
transformative
process,
what you might
call a reactive
side of this
transformative
process.
But then there's
also the more
active side of
this transformative
process as well
that I think
23 gets at a lot,
the signs of
corruption.
And he does
this in a lot
of places
beyond good
and evil
and a few
other places
where thinking
about like the
fruit of the
tree as the
tree's decadent,
it's rot,
it's the
containing of
the seeds,
the most
powerful,
great individuals
are sort of
like the,
Are sort of
contained within
the rotting,
corrupting fruit
of the tree.
And it's sort
of,
and so for
him,
this corruption,
this laxness,
this sort of
diffusion of
passions,
and like,
it's both a
diffusion of
passion,
but then it's
also an
intensification of
it,
right?
Not concentrated
in any one
area,
but sort of,
you know,
rotting throughout
the,
what was otherwise
a much more
sort of like
homogenous
body,
that this is
a transformation
not of
failure or of,
it's not a,
it's not a
transformation of
the rotting,
it's the
transformation of
the taking up
of the new
seeds,
of the greatness,
the destructive
power of the,
of the new
seeds taking,
of taking,
taking root.
The,
the sort of
the shedding,
the,
this active
shedding of,
of the,
of the older
body.
Right.
And that's,
that's like,
that's just a
different mechanism
of movement to
me than what I
see in,
in,
in Hegel.
Yeah.
It's not one of
exhaustion.
It's not,
it's not one of
negation.
It's not one of
failure.
It's one of,
um,
Well,
it's force.
Active aggression.
It's force,
forces acting on
other forces,
which obviously
ties it in with
Deleuze as well.
And it's,
I mean,
even just tone,
like aside from
the kind of
specifics of
the structure
of each of
their systems,
I feel like
Nietzsche is
just more invested
in futurity as
kind of central
to the,
um,
the,
not the intent,
but the kind of,
the purpose of
the project is
kind of,
it's all kind of
concerned with
futurity.
Whereas in Hegel,
and we can drop
him if we don't,
you know,
we don't need to
talk about Hegel
for this whole
podcast,
but futurity is
just given in
Hegel.
Obviously the
future kind of
weighs heavy in
the dialectic,
but it just sort
of happens to
you.
Um,
there's,
there's not a
sense of any
kind of agency
in terms of
enacting potential
futures.
Uh,
whereas for Nietzsche
that's at least
informing the,
the kind of
drive of the
Project,
I think.
So on those
lines,
I mean,
the,
the quote in
24 that I
thought you
were going to
read,
because it
says exactly
what you were
just saying,
Nathaniel,
but Europe
is sick,
but owes the
utmost gratitude
to her
incurability
and to the
eternal changes
in her
affliction,
these constantly
new conditions
and no less
constantly new
dangers,
pains,
media of
information
have finally
generated
intellectual
irritability
that almost
amounts to
genius and
is in any
case the
mother of
all genius.
You know,
but it relates
to me to,
uh,
one of the
passages that
struck me
this time,
is the question
of taste,
um,
and this is
section 39,
um,
the change,
and this is,
at least for
me,
like something
that I,
I feel like I
almost want to
start every
rhetoric class
with,
um,
the change in
general taste
is more
powerful than
that of
opinions.
Opinions,
along with all
proofs,
refutations,
and the
whole
intellectual
masquerade
are merely
symptoms of
a change in
taste,
and most
certainly
what not,
not what
they are still
often supposed
to be,
it's causes.
Right,
so the
intellectual is
the background
to something,
something else.
So what
changes general
taste?
The fact that
some individuals
who are powerful
and influential
announce without
any shame,
this is ridiculous,
this is absurd.
In short,
the judgment of
their taste and
nausea,
and then they
enforce it
tyrannically,
thus they coerce
many,
and gradually
still more,
develop a new
habit,
and eventually
all a new
need.
The reason why
these individuals
have different
feelings and
tastes is usually
to be found
in some oddity
of their
lifestyle,
nutrition,
digestion,
perhaps a
deficit or
excess of
organic salt
in their
blood and
brain,
in brief,
in their
phusus,
their nature.
They have
the courage
to side
with their
phusus and
to heed
its demands
down to
the subtlest
nuances.
Their
aesthetic and
oral judgments
are among
these subtlest
nuances of
the phusus.
So in that
sense,
it's like
taste is a
precursor to
judgment,
opinion,
taste as
this sort
of,
and now,
I mean,
it's obviously,
in that case,
it's taking the
body as the
kind of basis
over the
intellectual,
the intellectual
being a
secondary effect.
But,
you know,
it's like,
what changes
the general
taste?
How do you
change the
general taste?
Which is the
question of
Europe earlier,
it's the
question of
some of
those other
issues.
It's simply
because some
people are
different and
they're not
embarrassed about
that difference
and sort of
own their
difference and
own that they
don't like
X and
they do
like Y
and do so
in such a
way that
others go,
huh,
maybe Y is
more interesting
than I thought
and they develop
a habit or an
interest or a
need,
right?
And this is to
me where I
get a sense
of a social
difference is
that when you're
thinking of
futurity in those
terms,
it's so multiple
and diffuse.
It is not in
any way going
to be linear.
It's just simply
going to be
different folks
are going to
come along at
different times.
Now,
obviously,
it's a super
aristocratic
version.
of this
change,
although he
doesn't say
it's necessarily
wealthy people
or anything like
that,
but nevertheless,
it's like there
are certain
sort of special
people that
are the taste
establishers,
and the taste
comes from
idiosyncrasies
in these people's
dispositions,
like how they
happen to live,
what they
happen to eat,
with their
brain chemistry,
whatever it is.
It doesn't even
have to be like
a model that's
put out and
then rationally
argue that,
you know,
here's the
established taste,
here's my taste,
my taste is
better than
X.
It's more like
the strength of
the preference,
the taste
intervenes in
the common
taste.
It disrupts it
in some kind
of way.
I'm sure that
whatever that
new taste is,
it doesn't just
simply imitate
or represent
or replicate
the taste that
inaugurated it,
that it's much
more like a
differential.
It's just a
different kind
of thing.
It's like
TikTok to me.
That's all I
was thinking of
in reading that
is like,
isn't this
social media
culture,
right?
That certain
people that
we call them
influencers now
or whatever,
they have a
dispositional
inclination and
people glom
on to it.
I'm wondering
what's the
difference between
taste and
opinion then?
Because for me
they bleed into
each other so
much as to
become indistinguishable,
but I guess,
is he making the
distinguishment
that opinion
is more like
cognitive?
Yeah,
I think it's
the cognitive,
right?
Because I mean
it's opinions,
proofs,
refutations,
the whole
intellectual masquerade.
In other words,
this whole idea
of like,
if I can give
you reasons,
like reasons
should lead
the train
and he's like
reasons are
secondary,
reasons come
along afterwards.
Yeah.
It's not about
reasons.
I really think
that's true.
I mean,
to go back
to the social
media point,
I mean,
when you see
people engaging
in these
Twitter spats
or whatever
it is,
you see people
having a violent
reaction to
something.
That fundamentally
is a question
of taste.
For example,
when there's
a trans woman
who's succeeding
in a female
sport or
whatever,
and you have
people having
these homicidal
reactions and
then justifying
them cognitively
with opinions,
but all of
that is
symptomatic of
that gut-level
reaction.
So it's
all these
attempts to
justify what's
just a
kind of
frantic
hatred of
the other.
You know
what I mean?
I mean,
it makes me
think of a
couple of
the earlier
aphorisms.
One,
11 on
consciousness,
where he
undoes the
sort of
primacy of
consciousness as
this sort of
essential quality
of the human.
It's like,
no,
this is sort
of like in
the evolution
of things.
This is the
Johnny come
lately.
It's still
like a beta
testing and
it doesn't,
it's not really
like the body
doesn't really
trust it with
the keys yet.
It's sort of
like a little
playground,
but it doesn't
really do
much work.
And I think
this is also
that and even
just that fits
in with a lot
of the other
aphorisms that
we've,
that in here
that sort
of speak
to the
protective
nature of
consciousness,
the sort
of like as
a coping
mechanism of
sort of
keeping within
a herd and
then the sort
of the difficulty,
the rarity of
some kind of
courageousness of
consciousness,
thinking as a
kind of,
as a
disruptive
active force
and rather not
than just a
reinforcing force.
But then it
also makes me
think of,
and you know,
this is about
as aristocratic
as it comes.
You know,
Johnny said
I don't think
it has to be
aristocratic,
but the one
example he gives
on Napoleon
is quite
aristocratic.
So this is
still the signs
of corruption
toward the end,
23,
where he
brings up,
he brings up
Caesar at first,
you know,
he says,
once decay has
reached its peak
with the struggle
of all sorts
of tyrants,
the Caesar
always appears,
the final tyrant
who puts an
end to the
weary wrestling
for sole rule
by putting
weariness to
work for himself
and then way
down the page
he comes to
Napoleon.
So for this
great sort of
corruptor,
this great
seed of the
corrupted tree,
for he thinks
of himself,
and I should,
you should say
like decaying,
you know,
I always like
the language of
decay more than
corruption,
although he
ends this,
this was like,
well,
corruption is just
a rude word
for the autumn
of a people,
but,
you know,
so nonetheless,
he stays with
corruption.
So he thinks
of himself
and wants
himself to be
thought of
as Napoleon
once expressed
In his classic
manner,
and this is
Napoleon.
I have the
right to
answer all
charges against
me with an
eternal,
that is me.
I am apart
from all the
world and
accept conditions
from no one.
I want people
to submit even
to my fantasies
and to find it
natural when I
yield to this
or that
distraction.
And it's that
unsubstantiated
force of will,
like the
complete
abandonment
of even the
facade of needing
to substantiate
or legitimize
or,
you know,
create an opinion,
which is like
what we do
in our rhetoric
classes all the
time.
That's like the
point of what
we do.
And here,
this is just
the pure
force of will,
which,
you know,
we could say
that that's just
like the strong
man,
that's just sort
of like the
aggression of
the might
makes right.
You must obey,
but you can look
at it in another
way as well,
is that the
strength,
the character,
the vividness
of the taste
becomes intoxicating,
becomes seductive.
Yeah,
I wonder because
at times it feels
like he vacillates
between,
like there's one
section towards
the beginning
where he basically
says that
consciousness is a
relatively new
phenomenon,
right,
which means that
it's weak,
right,
it's precarious,
it's vulnerable.
And so it
seems like he's
pressing for,
not necessarily,
like some sort
of like reach
past it or
abandonment,
but then there's
other places like
In that same
section you're
referring to on
23 towards the
end where he
talks about the
individual and it
seems like he's
actually holding
that up and he
says individuals
being truly in
and for
themselves,
Hegel,
care,
as is well
known,
more for the
moment than do
their opposites,
the herd men,
for they consider
themselves no less
incalculable than
the future.
So it almost,
I mean maybe I'm
kind of misinterpreting
it here,
but it seems like
almost like letting
yourself into the
folds of
consciousness or
kind of like
affirming it in
some ways or
some of its
effects is actually
what leads you to
the step past or
to that
incalculable
future.
You know what I'm
saying?
Yeah,
so like over and
over again though,
I mean, I think
like individuals
are rare,
great individuals
are even rare
that the herd
is the primary
sort of state
of man
and so,
and often by the
way the most
heralded versions
of man as well
that sort of,
you know,
at the beginning
of this section
I think it is,
he juxtaposed
superstition
against faith
or religion.
You know,
as soon as
corruption sets in
anywhere,
a colorful
superstition
takes over
and the
previous
common
faith
of a
people
becomes
pale
and
powerless
against
it
for
superstition
is free
spiritedness
of the second
rank.
Whoever succumbs
to it selects
certain forms and
formulas that
appeal to him
and allows himself
some freedom
of choice
and, you know,
it's like this
is always the
sort of
maneuver
or the
transformation
of a
people
to a
sort of
like a
collection
of individuals
that, you
know,
this sort of
faith in some
kind of common
enterprise,
the self-sacrifice
for the state,
the sake of
the state.
I mean, yeah,
so consciousness
is new.
It's still
unrefined
and for the
most part
it doesn't
really have
all that much
activity
is why
taste is more
powerful than
opinion.
It's why
most thinking,
most cognitive
mental activity
is a matter
of sort of
reinforcing,
bolstering,
protecting,
coping with
the tailor.
It's not
active,
it's not
adventurous,
it is not,
it's the opposite
of all the things
that we might
romanticize
about it.
But that doesn't
mean that's what
it is all the
time and that
doesn't mean
that that's
all it's
possible of
becoming.
And, you know,
when he talks
about these
sort of great
individuals,
sometimes, you
know, it's like
here's a
consciousness that
it took an
entire people
to produce.
Here's a will
that it took
an entire
people to
produce.
And by the
way, that
consciousness,
that force of
will that a
people birthed
is also going
to probably
kill the
tree.
So, yeah,
like the
passage that I
read, it's
pretty straightforward
and we know
this from
Nietzsche and
many others
obviously, but
like, you
know, it's
a critique of
the primacy
of the
intellect.
And it's
an attempt to
kind of locate
in the body
the sort of
more powerful
element.
But there are
also those
places, and I
don't, these
aren't contradictory
at all, right,
where you say
like, but
actually, I
mean, it's
what Nathaniel
just said, and
I think it's
the second
point that he
made.
It's like the
intellect, it's
not simply that
it's capable of,
you know, becoming
more important, but
it's capable of
doing other kinds
of things,
right?
So that part
of it interests
him.
So on the one
hand, it's a
secondary derivative
phenomenon, but
it's capable of
doing something
other than
simply expressing
a taste.
So it's not
simply a
materialism in
its traditional
sense, right?
It's a
materialism with
a twist where
you would talk
about the
taste of
intellectual
directions,
right?
I mean, that
makes total
sense within
Nietzsche.
So that's
where it's
always, you
know, like,
it's easy to
read an
aphorism of
Nietzsche and
be like, ah,
okay, got it.
And that's
where it is.
I mean, and
the same thing
is true of
Hegel.
And, you
know, as
others have
Pointed, like
Plato or
whatever, it's
like, it's
easy to read
these things
and think, ah,
got the
argument.
But the
argument itself
gets differently
deployed.
That's where
that sense to
me of the
aphoristic
writing isn't
a stylistic
decision in
the sense of
like what he
happened to
do or came
up with an
aesthetic
preference.
It's very
much a
direct expression
of the
multiplicity of
diverse forces.
And that's
why it's not
an argument.
I mean, even
when I say it
that way, where
it's like, well,
the taste
section says
this, but
another section
says that.
It's almost, you
know, it's just
like a fragmented
teleology, but it's
still a teleology.
And it's really
not.
It's like each of
these things is
getting played
out.
They're a
related phenomena,
but they get
played out
differently, you
know, in
section 23, you
know, as the
section that I
just read, where,
you know, right
before the critique
of consciousness,
it's like these
things have
finally generated
an intellectual
irritability that
almost amounts to
genius and is
any case the
mother of genius.
Intellectual
irritability, right?
Like, that's the
domain where
something interesting
is happening for
him.
So, you know,
like, it's, like
I said, easy to
sort of say, okay,
go body, you
know, body is
good, body is
baseline, but I
don't think that
that's, and that's
important.
But the other part
of it is, when you
go into the body,
the body is a
multiplicity of
forces itself,
right?
So it's not
like, well, the
body is the
baseline.
It's not like a
genetic sort of
determinism of some
kind.
Right.
Well, thinking
about the
aphoristic style
though, too, I
think you could
think of all
that he's doing
in these aphorisms
are diagnosing,
you know, a
certain number of
forces, a certain
number of wills,
and because you
can't zoom out
from the
transcendent
perspective and
sort of, like,
enumerate all of
them and then
rank order them
and say, this is,
you know, in this
position, this is
in this position,
that, you know,
all he can really
do is he moves
from, and here's
how this force
works, and here's
how this one
works when it
encounters this
one, but there's
no predetermined
way in which these
forces relate to
each other.
I mean, they're
always relating to
each other
hierarchically, but
they don't have
that it's not
predetermined.
Just to add in,
they're not the
same force, right?
Like, any
particular force,
because force only
exists in relation,
it's not like, oh,
I'm going to look
at the intellect,
and I'm going to
play it out in
different places.
It's like, the
intellect is not
self-identical.
It becomes different
things.
Yeah, the
intellect becomes
different things.
I mean, since
the most profound
thing our time with
Deleuze's The
Logic of Sense did
for me, it's just
fun, like, I mean,
I feel like it was a
long time coming, but
it was just sort of
the nail in the
coffin for how I
think of paradoxes.
I don't buy paradoxes
anymore.
I mean, I don't buy
paradoxes in the
usual sense anymore,
sort of like an
opposition or a
stasis or a
stopping point.
I see paradoxes as
sense-making.
It only creates,
where one sees a
paradox, I see a
kind of a nuance, a
gradient, a
difference or a
deflection in, you
know, velocity and
direction.
You know, when I
see that this may
look like an
opposition or a
paradox between
consciousness and
the body, you
know, I see, well,
different articulations,
different senses of
intellect, of body and
their relationship to
each other.
Sure, the intellect
can be that
expression, but it
can also fold back
into the body and
be remade.
That's one of the
things for me, I
mean, I kind of
think we've talked
about this before,
but I think for me,
in order to say, and
you hear this all
the time, it's like
Nietzsche will
contradict himself
and that's a
positive quality
or whatever, and
it's like, that's
not exactly right.
Like, to say that
you contradict
yourself is, say,
like, in one
passage he says
the intellect is
unimportant and
another passage he
says the intellect
is everything.
To say that that
is a contradiction
requires extracting
both of those
things from the
context in which
they exist, placing
them side by side
on a logic, sort
of a logic puzzle.
Yeah, that's truth
claimed.
Right, in a, like,
really strictly
propositional way,
like, this says the
opposite of this
thing.
And so, what
you have to do,
there's a whole
operation of
forming something
that will have
been seen as a
contradiction that
is, that is a
dramatic
acontextualizing
and, you know,
logisticizing
logisticizing of a
series of
statements or
utterances or
whatever else.
And it's not
that that's, you
know, a wrong
thing to do, that's
one operation to
perform, but it's
also an operation,
right?
So it's not like
Nietzsche doesn't
contradict himself,
like, that to me
would be the strong
claim that I'd want
to make, is that
there are no
contradictions.
A contradiction
also, at least in
the vulgar sense,
would presuppose a
potential resolution,
right?
Like this, if a
paradox is just
kind of reduced to
a contradiction,
which I think is
kind of what you
were saying,
Nathaniel, then
there's a potential
for, we could
resolve this paradox,
whereas in Nietzsche,
the ambivalence and
the fluidity is
constitutive, and
that's what lends
the writing the
force, I think,
right?
Well, I think the
one way of thinking
of it is when you
think of it logically,
which is, I think,
the most important
of thinking about a
logical contradiction
is, as John said,
the principle of
self-identity,
right?
So X, it cannot
be the case that X,
both X is
true and X is
false at the same
time, right?
Where X is the
same in every
instance.
And so the only
ways, within that
logical domain, the
only ways of
attending to a
paradox like that is
to say it is a
true paradox or it
is a true
contradiction, which
means it's a dead
end and you don't
go down there, you
figured out where
to go, or it can
be resolved, which
means you just
haven't thought
about it hard and
hard enough, which
means it's not
actually a
contradiction, right?
And so the way
you could look at
Nietzsche's
contradictions, as
you say, there are
no contradictions.
There are only
intersections of
varying intensities,
speeds, relations.
So, you know, even
when, you know,
intellect A and
intellect B
intersect with each
other, you know,
it's never head
on, nullifying,
It's always sort
of like a, they
come at each
other at an
obtuse angle and
create singularities,
right?
So they don't
create logical
relationships between
propositions, they
create hesedities.
That's what a
paradox is.
They're generative.
They're generative
rather than like
stifling, right?
It's not a stopping
point when you see an
irresolvable
contradiction in
Nietzsche.
It's not like,
that's when you
start thinking.
That's what allows
for the partial
meanings, the
reversals of
interpretations, all
that kind of, all
the good stuff that
we like to kind of
ruminate on, that's
a product.
That would be the
Hegelian way of
approaching it, right?
Like what you just
articulated there is
that like, and that's
the sense of the
contradiction as
generative because it
allows you to move
beyond the
contradiction, resolve
it in some, in some
fashion to move on
to some, what will
then be subsequent
contradiction.
And, but I think
it's a different kind
of claim to say
there are no
contradictions.
Yeah, because
they wouldn't be
resolved, right?
I mean, this is the
sort of problem,
question sort of
thing.
Yeah, there's not
the answer, there's
not the solution.
It is a singularity
that is irresolvable,
right?
And I mean, it is
generative, just not
at the level of the
proposition, right?
Not at the level of
sort of like undoing
the web.
It becomes, you
know, you can see
apparent
contradictions are
bodies, right?
And so far as the
contradiction becomes
a binding between
two things, a
relation between
two things, an
association between
two things, then
it's just a body.
Say more about that, the
relation between two
things becoming a
body.
I've just been reading
a lot of A Thousand
Plateaus and any set
of relationships makes
Up a body, makes a
body, right?
In terms of like any
set of relationships is
capable of affecting and
being affected.
And you add or
subtract one
relationship, it's a
different body.
And, you know, the
essence, and, you
know, this is, this
could take us back to
Heidegger, but the
essence of anything is
not its essential
core, it is the
singularity, the
haseity of its
set of relationships.
What at any given
moment is it capable
of linking up to,
associating with?
Yeah.
And what's behind my
question there, and I
know the Deleuzean
resonance, and I've
never really been able
to kind of really
think that, is the
taste question, which
is that if the taste
question is not in the
intellect, but it's in
the body for Nietzsche,
what if the intellect
is in the business of
forming bodies, right?
Like of creating
different kinds of
relations.
So it would be
another, a next level
way of reading that
kind of materialism of
Nietzsche.
But I don't even, but
The intellect is not
part of the body for
Nietzsche, right?
It's just a part of the
body that's been
recently developed.
Right, but I'm just
saying that if it
forms contradiction,
and if we're talking
about it as the
relation of statements
as that which forms
a body, then we're
talking, then we
could very seriously
talk about the taste
of concepts.
Yeah.
And not just taste
being...
Oh, I see what you're
doing.
Right, not just taste
being the corporeal
thing that manifests
itself in intellectual
relations, but like
really, you know.
Yeah.
No.
And in ways that are
not sort of independent
of other sort of more
like, you know,
gustatory taste or
something like that.
That's right.
But you'd have to say
then that...
So then here, the
intellect, insofar as
it's ever existed,
has always been part
of the body, always
existing in relationship
with the rest of the
body.
And the only question
is, is what role does
it play?
Not within the...
It's a hierarchical
organization, but it's
relative position.
What, you know,
forces is it able to
exert and what forces
does it sort of...
How does it obey the
forces that are sort
of given it?
And sort of, you
know, it often has
that sort of subordinate
orientation to the
other forces of the
body, but that's not
its essence.
That's not, you know,
the only thing it's
capable of doing.
So if you're going to
talk about the
capacity to create
tastes of concepts,
then it would have to
be then the sort of
like the activity of
the intellect, sort
of now like re...
like appropriating,
dominating, working on
the rest of the body,
right?
Well, and he also
talks specifically like
concepts do have a
taste or they have a
preference.
They're not impartial,
right?
I mean, we've learned
this from Heidegger,
from Hegel, from
Nietzsche.
Concepts erase
difference, and that's
kind of like their
implicit purpose is to...
And for Nietzsche
throughout this book
one, he seems to
suggest that every
philosophical enterprise
is invested in
implicitly in a kind
of desire for
certainty, and that
like that threads
itself throughout the
whole project in these
kind of like unconscious
ways.
So every concept is in
some way symptomatic
of that, of that,
you know, embedded
desire, I think.
I don't know if that's
a universalizing
claim for Nietzsche,
but that seems to be
that like that's how
concepts orient
themselves regardless of
the intention of the
philosopher.
You'd have to think of
a different form of
concept here.
Now you've got me
really thinking of the...
So the concept in the
way that Deleuze takes
it up in Difference
and Repetition...
I was thinking,
What is Philosophy?
Well, I'm going to get
there, yeah.
But like in Difference
and Repetition and the
way that Nietzsche takes
it up in Truth and Lying
in a non-moral sense,
whereas the concept
aligned the lines of
that logical position
which is only at the
Level of proposition,
that's a level of
representation, reflection
and then ultimately
equality of erasing
differences to be able
to say that X is equal
to Y or that even that
X is equal to X.
And this becomes the
object of critique for
both Nietzsche and
Deleuze in a lot of
different ways.
But as soon as you start
thinking about the
intellect and relationship
to the body and
concepts as having a
certain kind of taste
that are produced,
I mean, I don't know
the equal sign seems to
go away and you get to
that more What Is
Philosophy notion of
making concepts not as
adequate relationships to
the world but as
different constellations of
forces.
Right.
You know, concepts that
are not representative of
or detached from some
supposedly material world
but that are themselves,
you know, actual bodies.
Bodies, right?
It seems like a both
and though, right?
Like for Nietzsche, it's
like he's always, he's
kind of critiquing this
symptom, right?
Where philosophers are
kind of guarding their
desire for truth.
But he's also saying that
you kind of have to live
That symptom out.
But he's also saying that
concepts do, are
generative and do things
other than represent.
So it's almost like
regardless of the
inflection or the
intention, concepts do
do work.
I guess your orientation
towards that problematic
is maybe the important
part for Nietzsche.
Well, and then also,
you know, in the very
sort of typical move
that I think we've all
become accustomed to
is, you know, like,
all right, we have a
binary, we have concepts
that create equations
between things and then
we have this other sort
of more like
interventionalist kind of
concept where concepts
concepts are made and
they don't have to
sort of adhere to that
propositional logic.
And then, like, of
course, you know, X was
always just a species of
Y.
And then say that, you
know, the critiqued
version of concept is
just another, is one
taste among many.
And yes, it does always
intervene and no, it
doesn't work the way
that we often think that
it works, but it does
work.
It does create
relationships.
It creates relationships
of false equivalencies
and relationships of
false equivalencies do a
lot of work in the
world.
You just have to, you
have to have the stomach
for it to be able to,
you know, to handle those
false equivalencies.
Yeah.
I mean, if you want to, I
could point to this one
section, 37.
I don't know if you were
about to say something,
John.
You look for, you're
ruminating over there,
but I'll go.
So it's owing to three
errors.
And first of all, I don't
know what these three
errors are, but like sort
of the second half of
that paragraph, he's kind
of critiquing a bunch of
philosophers, Voltaire,
Spinoza a little bit,
basically saying that, you
know, their investment in
knowledge is also an
investment in morality and
happiness.
And those connections
between the three are
often unconsidered.
So, you know, an
investment in knowledge
as a kind of objective
ideal is also loaded with
all these, you know,
moral implications.
And this is a fault of
philosophy, not being able
to recognize these
connections, the
moralizing of the
concept or some
Version of that.
And for me, I'm just
wondering if he's
saying that there's
something other than
that, right?
Like, it's a critique.
It's framed in the
language of a critique.
I mean, he's talking
about errors, but I'm
just wondering if Nietzsche
is saying here, like,
we can do better than
this version of
philosophy, you know?
Well, I don't know.
I mean, the three errors
there are.
So science has been
promoted during the last
centuries.
Yeah.
For three reasons.
One, it was by means of
science that one hoped to
understand God's goodness
and wisdom.
That was the motive of
the English, like Newton.
Two, one believed in the
absolute utility of
knowledge and especially
in the most intimate
association of morality,
knowledge, and happiness.
That was the motive of the
French.
Three, because one thought
that in science one
possessed and loved
something unselfish,
harmless, self-sufficient,
and truly innocent.
Right.
In which man's evil
impulses had no part
whatsoever.
This is Spinoza, and
some owing the three
errors.
So, like, I mean,
that's, I take that as
like, here are the
different investments
in knowledge.
And, again, so what he
doesn't do is say that
the investment in science
is bad.
He just says that the
motives driving them
are errors.
You know, each of those
three things is wrong.
There could be a fourth
thing, right?
There could be other
motives for knowledge,
which I think he thinks
his orientation is.
Right?
That it's not a question
of utility, innocence,
or God's goodness.
Right?
Right.
Well, I think he's right
in that.
I mean, he is doing
something different.
I mean, I feel like
you can kind of...
Well, I think he thinks
that they are doing
something different,
right, too, right?
Like, I mean, yes,
he does see, but he's
like, they were never
doing those things.
Like, that was never
really the investment.
That's the sense of the
critique, the enlightenment
critique that, you know,
that Nietzsche is famous
for, is all these ways
that people rationalize
the importance of
knowledge were kind of
bullshit rationalizations.
You know, when it was
a question of taste.
Right.
Because, like, the taste
is right after that,
right?
In reading, I was like,
the connections among
the different aphorisms,
like, as we go from
one to the next to the
next, it's like, I,
sometimes feel like I
have a grain of a
sense of why that
happened, that I
sometimes feel like it's
like, did he just have
a random conversation
at dinner with somebody
and, like, wrote this
fucking thing and put
it in there as number,
you know, 17 or
whatever, you know?
Like, I don't, I
don't see how that.
I don't feel the same.
You know.
But it does create,
there's, like, a
network, you know, like,
I, like, one takes me
to something else and
then bounces me over to
another one and I
don't, it's not, it
doesn't always just feel
like taste.
Oh, no, no, no.
It's just, this is the
one, this is the one
for me that I kept kind
of mentally coming back
to because I started
there in the middle of
the, in the middle of
book one, right?
And so I read
everything sort of
through this recurring
emphasis on, you know,
what we call kind of
standard materialist or,
you know, phenomenological,
let's just say, critique.
Yeah, I wonder, I mean,
it does, some of it
seems a little bit
haphazard, but I end up,
I thought a little bit
about the organization
earlier before the
podcast because this,
book one starts with
all those notions of,
like, how, like, evil
people have actually
preserved the species.
You remember when we
talked about that?
Right.
And I was like, okay,
this comes first.
This must be one of the
most important parts of
this book.
And then I was thinking
about my own writing
and I was like, what
comes first is not
always the important
thing at all.
It's rarely the
important thing.
Yeah, it's like,
sometimes, but like,
in my diss, I'm like,
chapter four is where
all the good stuff is.
So it's like, you have
to go to the middle
end for me.
If you make an album,
like, the hit song on
the album is never the
first cut.
No, no.
Yeah.
No, but it does set the
tone.
And yes, yes, yes.
Like, I don't know, the
teachers of the purpose
of existence.
I mean, to me,
actually, maybe the
most important one,
but only because it
sort of creates a
coordination between
pretty much all of the
other ones is the one
that Nate started us on
with on life.
It's like, what is
life?
This sort of act of
murdering, shedding,
killing, you know,
killing, right?
And then, yeah.
And, you know, in a
lot of these, there's
either different
variations of that,
or it's in different
ways that such, like,
life does this kind of
work, which is why I
turn to, you know,
how does weakness in
life do this?
And how does strength
in life do this?
You know, this, how
does reaction do this?
How does action do
this?
How does taste do
How does consciousness
do this?
I was talking to
Kara about this last
night, where, like,
thinking about, like,
sort of a state of
Nature, or just about
the brutality of
nature, right?
Where there's no
equality, it's just,
like, whoever's the
strongest, you get to
kill everybody else.
And it almost seems
like their entire,
I mean, I don't
know, there's probably
evolutionary data,
backing this up,
but there's entire
species where there
exists, their purpose
is just to be eaten
by the ecosystem,
right?
And so there's just,
like, this
constitutive unfairness
or inequality in
nature, but that you
can't just simply map
that onto humanity
either, because we've
done something
different, right?
But it's also not a
progression out of
that either.
So it's like, I...
Well, this is what I
love about what he
does to that seeming
being binary, where,
you know, like,
this...
John's brought this
up, this sort of,
like, the myth of
the material basis.
It's like, you know,
we're really just
animals, and we're
all just really
unequal, and we're
sort of...
And then we have
this facade of,
you know, the
social contract
and this doctrine
of equality, and
we pretend like
things are not...
are equal when
they really aren't,
and, you know,
like...
And then that
becomes...
That becomes,
like, really
shitty justification
for, you know,
certain people
to, like, feel
like they can
assert their will
over someone else,
or, like, I could
if I wasn't
hamstrung by, you
know, the mores
of society.
Right.
But it seems to
me that Nietzsche
just sort of
destroys, obliterates
that seeming being
dichotomy and so
many things.
It's like, no,
this doctrine of
equality did
something in the
world, and not
just sort of, like,
at the level of
social obligation.
It produced a
kind of consciousness.
kind of instinct.
It produced
tastes.
It produced...
It's, like...
Right.
It's a real
thing in the
world, not just
a sort of, you
know, fake
accounting of
the world.
Yeah, I mean...
You have to take
the critique of
representation
really seriously.
Right.
False representations
are no less real
than whatever else.
Yeah.
I have to...
Whenever I teach
it's certainly
like genealogy
in book two,
where it's, like,
the figure of...
The highest figure
that he envisions
is the individual,
like, the supreme
individual.
And I always have
to say, like,
that doesn't mean
what every one of
you thinks that
it means.
That it's not
about I am my own
dog and I control
my own destiny.
Like, and that's
how everyone reads
it, and it's very
easy to read it
that way.
Like, there's lots
of places in Nietzsche
that sound a lot
like that kind of
individual.
Like, hey, we're
all individuals,
and if people
would stop being
members of the herd,
and it's, like,
this notion of the
individual, absolutely
not beholden to
morality, not beholden
to sort of
conceptuality, to
time, like, it's
unthinkable, right?
It is.
It's so...
It is not, I am
my own dog and so I
should get to make
my own choices.
It's, like, no.
It's not, you're
making your own...
That's a consumerist
version of the
individual.
And so, and I...
And to me, it's
related to what
Nathaniel was just
saying there, it's
like, there's this...
I guess you could
say there's a tension
or a kind of
contradiction, but
there's a desire for
different forms of
the same figure
that emerges in
some ways
positively at
moments, but it's
always...
Everything that's
going to emerge
positive in place is
going to be
problematized somewhere
else.
And the same is
true for everything
that looks negative
in places is going
to be lionized
someplace else.
And that's that
sense of the...
It both constantly
gives you a position
to take and constantly
undermines the
position that you
previously had.
And that is the
Hegelian.
Like, I see, you
know, that dimension
of it being the
Hegelian thing.
But it also makes
it...
I mean, for me, one
of the things that
makes Nietzsche much
easier to read is that
he's always giving you
propositions and
positions.
like, boom!
You know?
And so that's why I
think that's one of
the things that's
really appealing to
like my 16-year-old
self when I started
reading this is it's
just like punk rock
mantra.
Other punk rock
You know?
Like, fuck the
herd, down with the
norms, and then...
And again, it's only
after years of reading
this stuff that I'm
like, ah, that
punk rock mantra
isn't it.
There's only one
tune, yeah.
That's one...
Right.
That's a good way
because it's there,
right?
It is there, but
it's one tune, and
there are a lot of
other harmonics
laying throughout the
whole thing.
Well, it's also...
I feel like that's
what lends his work
to misappropriation.
You know what I
mean?
Like, because if
you just latch on to
one aphorism, you
could be like, all
right, there's the
answer, and then...
Yeah, here's
Nietzsche's position
on X.
And then you
disregard every
other aphorism,
all of which
complicate the
proposition and the
one, you know?
But in some
level, what else
can you...
You know, I wish I
had sent this to
you guys.
I was just reading
an interview with
Daniel Smith, the one
at Purdue who does
The Deleuzian stuff,
and I have to say,
like, it's really
great, it's just sort
of why he's
interested in Deleuz
and, you know,
how it went.
And he says he's
like, you know, he
was at one point
really interested in
Derrida, but after
a time, he figured
he understood the
Derridian thing and
felt like he got it.
Whereas with Deleuz,
it's like it's in
perpetual variation.
He just can't get
it.
Like, he said, you
know, the best I can
do is kind of provide
a snapshot of a
particular moment.
And I remember
thinking, I was like,
no, it's not a
snapshot of a
particular moment.
It's you producing
a variation in
conjunction with those
variations, even if
that variation looks
like or feels like a
representation or a
snapshot or something
like that.
You know, it's like,
it was the perfect,
and he may not even
disagree with what I
just said.
He might be like,
yeah, that's exactly
right, but for the
purposes of an
interview.
That's what a
snapshot is, yeah.
snapshot is, right?
Like, yeah.
But it is that sense
of, because on the
one hand, I go like,
well, what else can
you do other than
this sort of
propositional, you
know, like, here's
the argument, here's
what I think about
the intellect.
And at the same
time, there is a
sensibility which I
guess you don't read
very often, honestly.
Like, I mean, think
of what it would
mean to be a
Nietzsche scholar in
that sense, because
you're trying to
study it to plumb
the depths, to get
the, even if it
means you've got to
read across books
and across aphorisms,
fine.
It just means it's a
complex theory of
epistemology or
whatever else.
But nevertheless, it
is a desire for,
like, I mean, I
don't know what
else, you know, if
you do the kind of
thing that I think
of, or that I feel
like I try to do,
at least in terms of
my writing with
Nietzsche, it's not
Nietzschean, in the
sense of, like, it's
not about Nietzsche,
right, it's, it's
not making, it's not
saying, like, Nietzsche's
version of Fusis is
more complex than
people think, like, it's
not an argument.
First time that, at
first, and I think
only time I ever
taught a seminar on
Nietzsche, and I was
like, I remember the
Charles Scott class,
where he began by,
like, here are the
five important ideas
of Nietzsche, and he
went through the five
important ideas, and
I just remember being
like, I think Charles
is fucking brilliant,
I've learned so much
from him, but reducing
Nietzsche to five
ideas, I don't care
which five it is, and
his whole point was
every other great
thinker has one
important idea, Nietzsche
has five, right, like,
so in other words, he
was doing it in a
totally laudatory way,
but I was like, gosh,
this seems so
reductive, so
reductive, and then I
ended up starting that
class, I told that
anecdote, and then I
was like, I have
number six, very
teachable.
And here's what I'm
going to do, I'm
going to add number
six, right, like,
because what else
are you going to do,
right, like, or
that's a way of
trying to make the
listicle version of
things mutate, because
number six shouldn't
just be another
number, it should be
that which undoes the
kind of schematic
hierarchicalization.
Or you just think of it
as an inflection,
right, because you
added style to it,
but then style that
becomes a thing that
inflects through
eternal return and all
the other ones.
This also, I mean,
the question of
pedagogy, too, is
really coming up for
me right now with
what you were saying,
John, because for me
it's like, if you want
to infuse your
pedagogy with theory,
which we all do in
some ways, this, it's
always a, for me, it's
always a project of
reduction, because to
teach these things, you
have to reduce them in
some way to make them,
you know, digestible for
students.
And I find that writing
through Nietzsche or
whoever, it's almost
the opposite, where
You're trying to
complexify it to a
point where it's like,
I would never teach
my chapter four of my
disc to my students,
you know what I mean,
because they're
different projects.
It's a different goal,
different aims involved.
And I wonder if that
is an important
distinction to make,
where pedagogy actually
has to be in some
ways reductive in
order to be effective.
See, like, this is
where I want to say
for undergrad.
If you see pedagogy as
sort of the application of
something else, then
you've created...
Then yes, then it will
be reductive.
Yes, and it will be
reductive, because then
there's the primary term
that must be then
expressed through the
secondary term, and
obviously, you know, it
doesn't matter what it
is, that could never,
ever happen.
And so you have to
think about it as a
contact point, as an
intersection, and then
so the theory isn't a
representation, it's an
inflection.
Right.
There's an inflection
point in which, you
know, so it's something
different is being made.
Because that's the
sense in which, because
what, and this doesn't
happen a lot, but it has
happened at times, and I'm
going to remake my theory
class, the undergrad theory
class I'm doing in the
spring, and I decide I'm
just going to throw my old
stuff away and totally
remake it, and I'm going
to remake it entirely
around, and this has
happened sometimes, it's
like, I want to try to do
like, Derrida to them.
Right.
Not teach them Derrida.
Like, I'm not going to, we're
not going to talk about the
word Derrida won't get
mentioned, deconstruction
won't get mentioned, it's
totally unnecessary.
But I want to do something,
I want to create a
structure of an engagement
with, I don't know, some
kind of text or something
that's more like an English
class thing, that we
actually do, you know, set
up your kind of binaries
and show how one is the
condition of possibility
and impossibility for the
other, right.
like, to do it.
And in that sense, I
wouldn't feel like I'm
reducing.
No.
Because what I'm
attempting to do is I'm
taking a kind of, in my
term now, like a style of
thinking and I'm trying to
infuse it into a different
experiment audience.
So, yeah, it's just an
experiment and success, I
mean, in fact, there was
that one section in there
that that was one of my
favorite that I, like,
underlined several times
where it's like, true
thinkers are
experimenters, they have
nothing to do with
success and failure.
Like, there's, that's,
that's for other people to
worry about.
This is just like, I
think of it because I've
always described, like,
the recent people that I've
dated, who we won't talk
about, like, I'm always
like, I want my life to be
bits.
I want to do bits.
Yeah.
Like, perpetually doing
bits.
Yeah.
And, and, but bits only
work if you have someone
else who's doing the bits
with you.
Yeah.
Or is at least involved to
recognize that there's a bit
going on because otherwise
you just end up getting
someone a teaching award
and nobody really knows,
you know, like, you know,
it's like, I want nonstop
bits.
So there's a, and that's
to me, that's how I think
of pedagogy when it comes
to theory is you're doing
bits.
Yeah.
And it's always bad when I try
to teach them Derrida or
Butler or any, any of these
theory folks, because as you
said, it becomes so
necessarily reductive.
Yeah.
You know?
I just find myself, I mean,
I'm talking about, like,
obviously undergrads.
I haven't, I haven't taught
any grad students yet, but I
find myself, you know, I, I
want to make the
conversations interesting and
complex and kind of
theory inclined, but I, I
need to, it's almost, it
necessitates a kind of
reduction, at least of the
terminology where you
can't, I can't be using all
these words that we use in
this podcast, or I'd be
losing everybody within the
first five minutes.
So, but I find that a
reduction of terminology
actually does in some ways
at a certain level, in
certain moments, reduces the
theory a little bit.
It can still be interesting.
It can still be compelling,
but it's not, it's not the
same as writing.
Well, it changes, it
changes, it changes it for,
I mean, that's exactly what
we're saying where X is not
identical to X, right?
Like, so, so Butler in your
writing is different than
Butler in your classroom.
And that's not a failure.
That is simply a
singularity, right?
Like, and, and Butler, it's
not even you doing it to
Butler, it's Butler doing it
to herself, or it's no one,
you know, it's life doing it
to whatever, however we want
to think of it.
Right.
And I mean, to me, that's a
really important pedagogical
point, but I also think it's a
point in terms of the writing
itself too, because it's not
just the writing is more
complex.
That is, I mean, I take that
point and that's, I feel
that way as well, but it's
also that there are
differential kinds of
complexity in the writing
depending on what you're
writing for.
Is it a dissertation chapter?
Is it a, is it a conference
talk?
Is it a, whatever, like all
those different forms are
going to have different types
of provocations, I guess.
That's, you know, I keep
coming back to Marco's book
series.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because it's just the best
named book series around,
right?
It's pretty fantastic.
It is why, like, even when
I'm doing my theory stuff, I, I
can only do it through close
reading.
I, it's so hard for me to
attend to whatever it is at the
level of argument, at the level
of like, all right, here's the
argument.
Is it good or bad?
Is it right or wrong?
Like I, like that's, those
are always the worst classes.
It always has to be like
getting inside of the reading,
following where it goes.
And then whatever theory thing
that I'm trying to do, or
didn't even know I was trying
to do, I can, there can,
there's a possibility for an
exchange where, you know, the
whatever influx of Nietzsche
or Deleuze or whatever else
that I'm doing, it starts to
work in there.
And then I don't need the
terminology.
I don't need the terminology
because it's just like, yeah,
what are the tensions in this
text?
Let's follow where they go.
And then, you know, it takes
on the language of my
students.
I'm like, oh, well, you
know, like I, if I were going
to probably go talk to, you
know, John or Nate about
this, I'd probably swap out a
lot of this book, this
terminology, but.
Well, whenever, whenever I
teach to undergrads, whenever
I teach performativity, I
teach performance, period.
Like that's what I teach.
Right.
Like I teach the notion, you
know, the exact opposite of
what I do when I go into
graduate classes, I say, here's
why performativity is not
performance.
And I just harp on it, harp on
it, harp on it.
And I just do the opposite.
And I have no problem or
qualms or issue with that at
all.
Yeah, no, no, no.
I don't, I don't have an
issue with it either.
It's just interesting how those
dynamics play out in the
different contexts.
Like I, for example, I, I
taught them, I taught them
and we talk, we talk through
Freud's notion of the
unconscious, you know, and
because it's, it's a
literature class basically
and the unconscious kind of
factors into every literary
piece in some way.
But in order for them to have
some leverage over the
concept, I figured I'm not
going to give them the
Hegelian version.
So I'm going to give them a
fairly simplified Freudian.
I mean, Freud's still
complex, so I even had to
reduce Freud, right?
But to give them something
that they can sample and
then sort of apply to the,
to the literature.
And I, again, yeah, I don't
think it's a problem for
them.
That's, I mean, isn't that
what Hegel teaches you,
right?
Like you start with
uncertainty and then you
complicate that and you get
to, you know, like, you
know, that's the ladder that
you're, you're climbing is
that, you know, you
intervene where you are,
right?
Like given, and you're
quite right.
Like I wouldn't have been
capable of hearing that
when I was 20 years old.
Jesus.
I mean, it's taken me, I
more and more, I come to
This thinking of like,
there's so much of this
stuff that I just could
not fucking really
understand until I got to
be like 50.
No joke, right?
Like not, I mean, it was
just, I don't know what
that is.
I don't know whether it
was just spending lots of
time with this stuff over
long periods of time, or
if it's a certain age of
my life where like
mortality becomes a
different kind of
question.
It's like, I just can't
get that stuff.
I see it even at the
level of like the stuff
we do in the sci-fi
class.
Like, you know, the
movies, it's like they
can't deal with the kind
of moral ambiguity that's
the only thing that
draws me to movies.
And they're just like,
it's just lost on them.
They're just confused.
You know?
And I don't think that
they're...
It took me until you
were 50 to learn all
these things too, John.
When you turned 50, I
learned it all.
But I think, like, people
also have a, you know, a
taste or an inclination for
theory too.
I mean, in that, I don't
know where that comes from,
but I see it in a select
few students where I'm
like, oh, they're willing
to play with language and
they're experimenting with
these concepts and ideas in
a way that's generative,
whereas most people either
can't or are unwilling to
do that.
And it's just dispositions.
Thinking is a fun thing
for some people, including
the three of us, and it's
just not a fun thing for
the vast majority of
people.
Right.
I mean, that to me is
like, that's the crux of
relationship problems in
general.
It's like, I really like
thinking, can I find anyone
else who does?
The answer is no.
I wanted to, and maybe we
can do this next time, but
we can just earmark it.
Go back to the question of
the individual, and it just
makes me think, very
interested in the, to go
back to the genealogy and
kind of juxtapose some of
that stuff that's going on
here with Napoleon, Caesar,
you know, the rotten fruit,
just that, you know, the
individual has to pass
through all of this hurt
stuff.
The hurt stuff doesn't just
go away, and it doesn't
just be coming like, I'm
the shit, you know,
whatever, like, I deserve
all this stuff, right?
Right.
It's, it becomes differently
inflected, but, you know,
it's the, the individual is
The one who has the
prerogative to make
promises.
That's right.
Who has the capacity, the
strength of will, and the
capacity to attend to
otherness, right?
Right.
Not the one who only gives
a shit about myself.
It's not me, me, me.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean, but that's, and you
hear it all the time, I
mean, the resistance, among
the resistances to Nietzsche,
obviously the aristocratic
ethos, but the emphasis on
individualism, and it's
like, yeah, you're not
wrong, but it's not that
kind of individualism, but
it's not the individualism
you're looking for.